tonight Senate Democrats are calling for
the Pentagon to launch an independent
inspector general's investigation into
the Navy's decision to relieve the
captain of the USS Theodore Roosevelt
Roosevelt from his post captain Bret
Crozier who you see here sounded the
alarm over the cove at 19 outbreak that
was on board his aircraft carrier he
wrote a letter to Navy officials on
Sunday calling for the ship's immediate
evacuation
after more than a hundred sailors tested
positive on board now the Acting
Secretary of the Navy says that the
captain acted without discussing the
letter with his immediate commander and
sent the letter over an unsecured
unclassified email system but it was
copied to 20 or 30 other people okay
that that's just not acceptable he did
not take care and what that did is
created a panic on the a little bit of a
panic on the ship that demonstrated the
extremely poor judgment in the middle of
a crisis
because what it's done it's created a
firestorm it's created doubts about the
ship's ability to go to see if it needs
to it's created doubt among the families
about the health of their sailors and
that was a completely unnecessary thing
to do in the midst of a crisis join me
now General Jack Keane retired four-star
general and Fox News senior strategic
analyst general Keane always good to see
you what's your take on this story yeah
I think it's pretty unfortunate
circumstances taking place here because
everybody involved here is
well-intentioned and you know my first
my first issue with it is the the
Secretary of the Navy listen he's
completely justified and taking any
actions for the reasons he stated but
why is he doing that is the question I'm
asked and he's he's got at least four
Admirals between him and his captain
that's over a hundred years of
experience that are involved in Navy
operations if you got a concern about
somebody who's running the most powerful
symbol of American power in this country
which is an aircraft carrier let let
those Admirals make that assessment and
make the judgment about
but the Navy secretary got himself
personally invested in this I understand
he may have had a conversation with the
captain last week so that that's issue
one for me and if you're doing that
if you're making those decisions and not
letting the Admiral make those decisions
at lower levels aren't you going around
the chain of command and weakening that
chain to come in and doing something
like that in my judgment that's true but
I'll go back to it he has the authority
to do it secondly is why do it now the
[ __ ] the the Roosevelt is not
operationally deployed there is a strike
command group that's on that ship that's
still functioning and they have control
of the other ships but the ships company
by and large are all focused on one on
sheltering on isolation and testing the
crew and getting the now 140 who are ill
taken care of 90 something and of those
are symptomatic we all know that a Navy
captain is a larger-than-life figure on
a ship everybody has an opinion about
that captain who serves on that ship
most of them are very favorable because
we got great people out there serving
and to remove that person in the middle
of the of the crisis that's threatening
the lives of the people on that ship
seems to me that timing is off let's
let's make a judgement about the mistake
he may have made but let let him
continue there until the full assessment
is is completed and gets let's get some
emotional separation from this the third
thing is the captain himself I mean why
would he write a letter after he's had
plenty of dialog with his chain of
command on a non-secure net and then
copy people on that letter who were not
in his chain of command some of them are
subordinate to him that is absolutely a
boneheaded mistake in my view note
despite the fact is well-intentioned
obviously he was talking to his chain of
command before they got to Guam very
high in a chain of command and they knew
he had a lot of concern they were
working on trying to get him the knees
and at some point over the weekend I'm
convinced he must have come to the
conclusion
hey listen they're not moving fast
enough I've got to do something about
this
and that sparked the letter but there
are other ways to handle it that whole
chain of command if he wanted him on a
vtc to talk to them about the problem
he's got to include the Chief of Naval
Operations and go all the way to the top
with everybody else on that vtc he would
have got that vtc without any problem
with some whatsoever why do that and and
that judgment call is what is what an
issue here well and it may be one that
he regrets I have no idea but as you say
he clearly got to the point or I would
assume just from this sequence of events
that he got to the point where he felt
like nobody was listening to him and
that his his people were in a bad
situation that he wanted to help them
out of listen to this video this is them
cheering him on as he was leaving the
ship they're chanting captain Crozier
captain Crozier
I mean that's a lot of folks general
keen who seemed to feel like he was he
had their back well that to my point I
mean he's a larger-than-life figure on
that on that ship everybody knows who
you is and you you can see the send-off
that he's getting from many of the crew
members you know obviously don't agree
with that decision here emotionally
invested in this themselves I go back to
my original point I mean it it's an
unfortunate situation I think it could
have been better handled I believe when
you're dealing with issues that take
place in the chain of command those who
are closest to that chain in command
they know the facts they know the people
involved let them make the decisions and
the assessment about that with some
people in the Pentagon making decisions
about a guy who's running the ship out
in the Pacific I think we I think that's
well-intentioned you have the authority
to do it but I think it would better
serve that we leave it to people much
closer to the problem Jarrell Keene
always good to get your thoughts thank
you sir good to see you tonight yes they
were good talking to you Martha